a luta
eu tinha 24 anos e era uma noite de
domingo quando eu resolvi pegar um álbum
de fotografias minhas antigas e uma foto
especial me fez voltar no tempo
era eu vou andando num a nave espacial
no parque de diversões aqui em recife e
naquele momento eu me reencontrei com o
meu eu criança eu fui um menino que
sonhava conhecer o mundo num dos meus
aniversários de criança quando meu pai
me perguntou o que eu queria ganhar de
presente eu respondi eu quero conhecer
timbaúba
eu não queria ir pra disney eu não
queria uma festa em um bando de
presentes eu queria apenas conhecer
timbaúba aos 10 anos de idade eu já
tinha conhecido o sertão já tinha
conhecido a floresta amazônica a cidade
maravilhosa e lógico tem paúba as
lembranças evoluíram cheguei no período
da grande viagem do meu pai que partiu
muito cedo e que nos fez enfrentar a
vida sem a sua presença já estudante
universitário fazendo engenharia um bom
aluno e depois evoluir mas um pouco
cheguei na minha fase de criança criança
que eu nunca deixei de ser mas na
verdade eu já era um adulto recém
formado com 24 anos e percebi que eu não
era feliz
eu sentia muito mais alegria quando eu
ouvia as histórias dos trabalhadores da
construção civil do que com a exatidão
do concreto e da engenharia e ali eu
precisei tomar uma grande decisão
no dia seguinte eu cheguei no trabalho
entreguei minha carta de demissão e
resolvi que eu precisava sair pra ver
mas sair pra onde ir a qualquer lugar eu
precisava sair para ver o importante era
eu me libertar
não pensem que a liberdade é uma coisa
fácil
o escritor português chamado afonso cruz
ele diz que há
lojas de pássaros são os locais
construídos com mais restrições na vida
nelas em gaiolas por todos os lados
inclusive dentro dos pássaros é por isso
que quando as portas se abrem os
canários olham para o outro lado porque
olhar para a liberdade é muito difícil
e naquele momento eu olhei e eu me
libertei e nessa libertação eu precisei
fazer vários caminhos
eu andei nos trens na índia andei nos
caminhões no sertão
andei passou um pouco andei nos barcos
nos rios da amazônia andei nas balsas do
rio são francisco
andei até quando não podiam contar com
meus próprios pés e sempre que voltava
dessas viagens e mostrava minhas fotos
as pessoas diziam
nossa como suas fotos são diferentes e
eu dizia
são fotos do mundo real
o restaurante abençoado rap ao é a
esquina da moda que só vendia redes
o fusca árvore de natal a casa de taipa
no sertão com duas antenas parabólicas
uma placa em árabe que aparece um dos
meus sobrenomes brasileiro
o uberlândia vial ea maravilhosa
possibilidade de fretar esperança eu
também trazia imagens que representava a
um mundo visto a partir das pessoas e
famílias tradicionais marroquinas e
imersas na cultura globalizada o doce
encantador olhar da filha da vendedora
de farinha em óbidos o cuidado das
mulheres ambulantes na colômbia em
proteger seus lindos cabelos negros
contra a poeira das estradas que iríamos
pegar
eram muitos olhares os pintados na serra
das araras grandes sertões veredas e
seus esforços magníficos em aprender a
ler ea doce jovem guardiã da loja baby
fashion mais muito mais do que imagens
eu trazia a história de pessoas
de reis e rainhas histórias de pessoas
comuns
certo dia eu estava numa rodoviária em
serra talhada e a observar o carinho de
um homem com seu monte de filhos e
ocorrido foi uma lanchonete e comprei um
bocado de pacote de biscoitos para poder
servir de isca e cheguei perto dele e
perguntei se podia oferecer e começamos
a conversar e ele me disse que estava
indo pra marabá encontrar os outros
filhos
eu devo ter arregalados olhos muito
grande e ele falou assim tá vendo ela
lhe a minha mulher ela está grávida
homem entendi uma coisa minha mãe teve
20 filhos e hoje só tem eu vivo para dar
amor e cuidar dela
então a gente precisa ter muitos filhos
pra quando eles forem morrendo
pelo menos sobre a 1 pra nos dar amor eu
pensei em argumentar mas eu pensei 'não
eu sou um ser externo
eu estou de um lado que eu só consigo
ver a dor ele estar do lado que consegue
ver o amor
naquele momento eu entendi o quanto é
importante olharmos a vida por várias
óticas e aí eu saí do sertão e fui parar
no rajastão na índia aonde eu tive o
carro que estava detido e usava um colar
de madeira que tinham estatura pendurado
caminhando no meio dos policiais aquele
estatuto chama atenção e o policial me
chama para conversar e eu expliquei para
ele que aquele estatuto tinha sido feito
por um artesão no sertão do piauí e
comecei a contar histórias do sertão pra
ele e foram chegando outros policiais
outros policiais e lembrei de um
episódio muito engraçado onde dona lindu
até a artesã depois de comer caiu na
gargalhada e eu perguntei dona linda
porque a quito tantos rio e ela decide
julho é porque a felicidade vem das
tripas
depois que a gente come o mundo fica
muito mais feliz
naquele momento aquele policial parou
olhou pra mim e me perguntou por que é
que você é um homem que já andou tanto
pelo mundo está fazendo num lugar tão
feio feito e se eu pensei em dizer que
era bonito e eu simplesmente disse
é preciso tirar a venda dos olhos pra
gente ver o que realmente tem
eles param olham pra mim e dizem deixa
julho e ele precisa ver mais e ter mais
histórias pra contar e eu fui e cheguei
num seminário onde eu apresentava
conceitos de desenvolvimento territorial
e um palestra e um participante no
auditório me perguntou
é verdade que na índia ainda hoje
existem marajás e dá lhes é verdade que
ainda tem tanta pobreza e eu do palco
que eu tava eu tinha essa vista e eu
falei aqui não aqui não será que também
temos marajás e da letra
talvez é preciso tirarmos a venda dos
olhos pra vermos o que realmente temos
e quanto à questão da pobreza eu te
respondo contando uma outra história
certa vez eu estava num encontro em uma
fundação e uma pessoa uma produtora
receber um pagamento e ela separou os
montinhos de dinheiro eu perguntei pra
que são dessa separação nem aí pra que
essas montanhas de dinheiro e se é pra
pagar o meu barraco comprar o botijão de
gás pagar a luz e esse eu vou me dar um
presente e eu naquele momento dei um
abraço nele não perguntei qual era o
presente e aí
pouco tempo depois eu tô no self-service
como um popular encontro aneide lá
almoço com ela no final do curso sua
comanda e digo nem de tu és minha
convidada e ela disse hoje não
esse é o meu presente e eu perguntei
qual é o teu presente neide
é pelo menos uma vez na vida poder
escolher o que eu vou comer naquele
momento eu disse pro homem e eu entendi
o verdadeiro conceito de pobreza e
pobreza não é só não ter o que comer
pobreza é também não ter o direito de
escolha e aí
continuando no âmbito da pobreza e da
riqueza esse ano alguns meses atrás eu
estava andando nas ruas em rio branco no
acre visitar os projetos no reino atriz
e encontrei a bsi ma nenê uma índia
kaxinawá de 37 anos mãe e pai de sete
filhos e uma neta
em menos de cinco minutos de conversa e
perguntei se podia na casa dela
ao chegar lá dentro em sua casa aonde o
canto dos pássaros entrava pelas venda
das madeiras
as portas não existiam eram cortinas de
tecidos coloridos restos de tecidos
sentamos no fundo da casa
ela pega o seu tem ar manual começa a
produzir algumas peças e eu muito
preocupado com a sua situação financeira
ela percebe e de s
o júlio fica assim não ontem abrir a
minha despensa e vi que só tinha comida
até hoje
sabe o que eu fiz eu fui na frente da
minha casa abrir a porta do céu bonito
eu fiquei olhando pro céu azul veio uma
brisa bateu em meu rosto e eu pensei que
bom que eu tenho comida hoje e amanhã eu
penso amanhã e aí o amanhã que é hoje
você chegou veio aqui comprou os
produtos e eu tenho comida de novo então
entendi julho que está vendo esse teu
short essa tua sandália havaiana e esse
teu relógio
nada disso tem valor o que tem valor
julho
não é o que a gente tem é o que a gente
deixa no caminho
outra coisa julho nem tudo que vocês
brancos acham que precisa ter
ou melhor que vocês acham que a gente
precisa ter é o que realmente nós
precisamos ali mais do que nunca eu me
certifiquei de um pensamento que eu
carrego ao longo da minha vida
profissional
nós não sabemos o que é melhor para os
outros é preciso ouvirmos o que os
outros têm a dizer
mas contando histórias da índia e do
acre que parecem ser histórias de
lugares tão distantes será que são
realmente tão distante
será mas antes de sair da casa da bsi ma
nenê
o sol estava se pondo e como uma mágica
como naamã que é um sonho em seu dialeto
opare que é o sol trouxe luz ao meu que
a minha
por isso eu estou aqui mas voltando à
questão se a índia ou a criar perto
longe eu estava num barco há muitos anos
atrás da região amazônica e o senhor me
perguntou julho em que hilton moras ele
é perto ou longe eu falei danos é eu
moro no rio chamado oceano atlântico
perto longe esse rio
eu falei para o rio que o senhor mora é
perto ou longe a quantas horas daqui e
ele deu uma risadinha bem suave e falou
tá sete dias daqui eu falei é perto hoje
não é nem de perto nem longe o ano
passado eu estava em são paulo numa
reunião ea instituição organizava uma
viagem para ir numa aldeia comigo a onde
imaginavam que iriam sair de são paulo
de madrugada desembarcar em são paulo de
manhã e que na noite do mesmo dia ia
chegar na comunidade a 300 quilômetros
de manaus
e eu disse talvez esses 300 quilômetros
possa ser muito mais distante do que
vocês imaginam e eles começaram a rir
e eu fui contei essa história e disse
perto e longe é muito relativo
assim como tudo na vida e as certezas
que essas histórias me trouxeram foram
muitas mas a primeira é que tudo é tão
relativo
quem somos nós para sabermos o que é
melhor para os outros porque não sairmos
daquele palco da arrogância e da
intelectualidade aonde a gente definir
projetos e programas de desenvolvimento
territorial e de negócios do impacto
dizendo que é melhor para os outros se a
gente não chega para conversar e em pra
entender quais são os sonhos
possibilidades e desejo dos outros
eu trouxe uma outra certeza também muito
grande é que é preciso sairmos para ver
mas muitas vezes e se sair pra ver é
inicialmente sairmos de dentro de nós
mesmos
o cantor rubel ele tem uma música
chamada partilhar que eu me identifico
muito
ela diz assim um trechinho se for
preciso eu crio alguma máquina mais
rápida que a dúvida mas subi tac a
lágrima viaja toda a força e num
instante de saudade e dor
eu chego aqui pra dizer que eu vim te vê
e o que eu faço no meu dia a dia é eu
quero partilhar eu quero partilhar a
vida boa com você eu quero partilhar eu
quero partilhar a vida boa com você eu
quero partilhar a minha gente a vida boa
real e possível com vocês o que eu faço
hoje faça um bom tempo é que eu
introduzi na minha metodologia de
trabalho no desenvolvimento territorial
e nos negócios do impacto
a importância de olhar para a
multiplicidade da vida real e entender
acima de tudo que cada povo tenham
querer cada terra tem seu tempo e que
nós precisamos viver hoje
acima de tudo eu me reencontrei com
aquela criança que um dia eu fui e que
sonhava em ser um mundo mas eu entendi
que não era o mundo físico que eu queria
conhecer era o mundo real e possível das
pessoas e tudo o que eu sou hoje o pouco
que eu sou hoje
mas que eu tenho muita honra de ser é
que aquele menino que um dia em que
sonhou em conhecer o mundo se tornou o
facilitador de trocas e tudo que eu
tenho hoje eu devo aquelas pessoas que
um dia se perguntar ele se permitiram
trocar histórias comigo a todos vocês
que um dia se permitiram trocar
histórias comigo tenham certeza que hoje
eu sou um pouco de cada um de vocês
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]